>> Ed: AT CHICAGO’S
COOK COUNTY JAIL RELEASING OVER
1300 INMATES TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF COVID-19.
IT’S A HOT SPOT WITH ONE OF THE
LARGEST CLUSTERS IN THE NATION.
MATT FINN IS LIVE IN CHICAGO.
WE SEEN THIS HAPPEN IN OTHER
CITIES AS WELL AND IT’S A BIG,
BIG ISSUE.
GOOD MORNING.
>> ED, CITIES NATIONWIDE ARE
RELEASING PRISONERS AND
DETAINEES SAYING THAT
CORONAVIRUS IS SPREADING SO
FIERCELY INSIDE PRISON THEY
BASICALLY HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
RELEASE PEOPLE TO MAKE ROOM AND
POTENTIALLY SAVE LIVES.
OF THE COOK COUNTY PRESENT HERE
IN CHICAGO AT ONE POINT WAS
CONSIDERED THE NATION’S GREATEST
HOT SPOT FOR COVID-19.
DETAINEES ARE NOW PUTTING UP
SIGNS THE WINDOWS SAME "DON’T
LET US DIE" AND "WE MATTER."
THERE ARE MORE THAN 500 CASES OF
CORONAVIRUS INSIDE THE FACILITY
IS.
306 INMATES, 218 STAFF THAT HAVE
TO GO ON TO THEIR FAMILY.
THEY’VE RELEASED AT LEAST 1300
PRISONERS AND DETAINEES SO FAR
AND IDENTIFIED AT LEAST 80 MORE
CUPS EIGHT THAT ARE SERIOUSLY
ILL.
THE SHERIFF TELLS FOX NEWS THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER IS A RELEASING
ITS DETAINEES WITHIN CERTAIN
CRITERIA.
SOME THAT ARE ELDERLY, I HAVE
SERIOUS MEDICAL CONDITION OR ARE
CONSIDERED NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS.
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER SAYS UP TO
90% OF DETAINEES IN THE
COOK COUNTY JAIL ARE CONSIDERED